the esteemed doctor thomas morstead
entered the cell of the anomaly
he'd been warned and even chastised by
his colleagues
but who in the foundation could tell him
what to do he was the best at what he
did
maybe the greatest in the whole history
of the foundation
as he entered the room scp-049 bit in
welcome
cordial as always so polite in fact that
you'd never guess you were talking
to a killer dr morstead knew the truth
of what he was dealing with
but he also believed he could get
through to zero four nine
calm him exercise the devil from him
it was the meeting of two great minds
one of them human
one of them part human part something
that has never been clear
it was to be a battle of wits and like
so many great battles
this one would turn into a massacre
before we get to that fateful meeting
there are some things you should know
about the anomaly known as scp-049
if you saw him in the street the first
thing you'd think of was playing
because zero four nine always looked the
same a man dressed in black robes with a
plague doctor's mask
but this wasn't a costume that could be
taken off in fact it wasn't a costume at
all
it was him the robes had grown out of
him like an exoskeleton
that horrible mask with the pointed nose
wasn't covering his face
it was his face a kind of shell that had
seemingly sprouted from bone
the first reports came during world war
ii in a picturesque town in the south of
france called montevallo people had
begun going missing
children disappeared from their beds in
the middle of the night and weren't seen
again
adults went to the market and never
returned local authorities searched high
and low
they scoured nearby woods and dragged
the rivers but nothing was found
because what was happening wasn't
criminal there was no clue they could
stumble upon
or eyewitness who would break the case
no this was something else
something that the townsfolk could never
understand word spread
and that's when a search and discovery
team was sent from the foundation
it was a cold dark night in january of
1941
when the team found what they were
looking for they walked through the open
door of a small house located not too
far from the grand chateau de luis to
find a masked man sitting next to an
open fire
and he wasn't alone the floor around him
looked like it was moving
upon closer inspection the team saw that
the floor was covered with
writhing grasping bodies its patience
as it called them bienvenue chamois said
the thing
welcome to my home those so-called
patients crawled towards the team
intent it seemed to cause harm the
hostiles
now known as scp-049-a
were deemed dangerous and had to be
eliminated a sight it seemed
that didn't bother 0-4-9 in the
slightest he just sat there
occasionally looking up from writing
notes in a leather-bound book as his
patients were gunned down
once the carnage ended it simply closed
its book
stood up and allowed itself to be
escorted away
and that's the story of how 049 ended up
at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell
research sector 02 site 19. the few that
came into contact with 049 remarked that
it was a pleasure for them
with its impeccable manners vast
knowledge of medicine and human anatomy
sharp tongue and stinging went they
almost became spellbound listening to it
caught in the throes of its charms until
with the simple touch of its hand
it would drain the life from them that's
why scp-049 was classified as a euclid
that's why armed guards were always
stationed outside itself
it's why doctors took great precautions
when in its presence
and it's why dr morstead should have
known better remember
when 049 was discovered in france it
willingly went with the team
like it was happy it had been found as
if it had planned its own capture
when it arrived at the facility it
didn't act like it was contained against
its well
it was like it was returning home
initial findings as to the biology of
049 were that it didn't require any
sustenance at all
not even water it seemed content to be
left alone with its notebooks
it did not object when it was asked if
it could share some of its notes and
gladly handed over its journals
but upon examination it was discovered
that they were written in the language
that no linguist or cryptologist
has so far been able to translate it's
apparent that 049 derives much
satisfaction from seeing
so-called experts struggle over its text
unable to read those notes
a long line of doctors visited 049 in
itself
each fascinated by what they beheld it
was learned that it has traveled the
globe
it speaks many languages but prefers to
speak what it calls
le long de la mor french it asks for
only one thing
warm-blooded animals the facility agreed
to supply 049 with various kinds
including rabbits cattle and even an ape
on one occasion
just like with humans it could kill the
animals with a mere touch of its hand
sucking the life right out of them but
that wasn't even the most incredible
part
soon those animals would rise again as
if reanimated by 049
they would become for all intents and
purposes the living dead
and they were hostile after several
unfortunate incidents
they were taken from the cell the moment
they arose and disposed of in the
incinerator
this was not to the liking of 049 who
would claim
it had cured the animals for it the
world was sick
it saw plague and pestilence everywhere
and the meaning of its existence was
to rid the world of disease humans
it said contained a virus and had to be
cleansed
in the first days after arriving at the
facility 049 didn't seem to pose a
threat to humans
it was quite friendly in fact it seemed
aware of the fear it caused in staff
and would often go out of its way to
make them feel comfortable and safe
this was a ruse of course or a canard as
049 like to say
it had no intention to help humans no
it had come for humans it wasn't trapped
it had set a trap one of the first
people to truly upset 049 was dr raymond
hamm
a well-respected physician that had
twice been a contender for the nobel
prize for his more mainstream work what
had confused dr hamm the most was not
zero four nine's close-like
exoskeleton or even his ability to
reanimate the dead
but the bag that it used zero four nine
was somehow able to pull a seemingly
endless supply of surgical tools from
that bag
sometimes it would even pull out objects
that were somehow larger than the bag
itself
it was as if the bag connected to
somewhere else and that's what dr ham
wanted to talk about on that fateful day
with 049 on one side of the cell and dr
ham on the other
he asked how is it that you can produce
a great quantity of tools from that bag
i've observed you and it seems to me
that you are doing the impossible
dear doctor replied049 the scourge
the great dying cannot be fought with a
handful of toys
my bag is merely the product of my
imagination
it gives me what i require you dear sir
it seems are limited by your imagination
it stopped for a second or two and
stared at dr ham i detect you are
unwell it said in a voice not as amiable
as before
it's just a cold said the doctor ah just
the cold
if you had seen what i have seen you
would not utter such insulting words
dr ham pulled out some papers from a
briefcase and approached 049
holding them close enough so it could
read them you see said dr ham pointing
to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not diseased
they were perfectly healthy before they
died and your so-called kiera
it turned them into something quite
terrible we found that if they were left
alone they began to eat each other
and then themselves 049 did not respond
and after a brief pause said only a good
day to your doctor
please close the door on your way out
you should get some lists
ham refused to go and instead turn the
conversation to this real interest
the bag demanding that 049 let him see
inside of him
very well doctor 049 said in private
049 began to pull a series of long metal
poles out of its bag
followed by a rolled up curtain that it
hung between them creating a kind of
medical tent around dr ham
it seemed to stare for just a moment
into the observation camera outside of
itself
before whipping the curtains shut dr ham
was discovered three hours later
crawling around the floor of zero four
nine's cell now another mindless undead
when he was retrieved by security 049
didn't even look up from his notebook
dr ham didn't get the incinerator
treatment but he did receive a fatal
dose of drugs
a mercy a removal team was sent to 049
cell but it had said there was no need
for special extraction
techniques it would go willingly
wherever they wanted to go
it was not it said an enemy of the
people the hippocratic oath forbids me
to hurt a human being
it said while walking to the
interrogation center my only desire
is to offer you my services and
expertise
the floors and walls of the
interrogation center room were painted a
bright white
even the table was white which
contrasted with zero four nine
a mass of black sitting in the middle of
the room during the interrogation
it refused to admit or even accept that
it had killed dr ham
i cured him i removed the pestilence
from his body
it said it was later asked if it
regretted its actions to which it
replied
well good sir one always regrets the
loss of a colleague for any reason
but i stand by my actions the pestilence
must be abated
before it is too late every two weeks
from that point
zero four nine was given animals the
scientists at the facility observed it
time and again touching the animals
killing them before producing a saw or
scalpel and opening them
up organs would be carefully removed
with perfect precision it was astounding
to even train surgeons just how talented
049 was
i require a close relative of yours said
049 one day to a young doctor
who expressed shock that it was asked
for one of the doctor's family members
i mean a great eight said zero four nine
not your dear aunt there were several
instances of 049 displaying a crude
sense of humor
staff would almost forget that the thing
that they were talking to wasn't
human almost and it was dr thomas
morestad that had supplied the great
apes
orangutans in fact that had been rescued
from the rainforests of borneo
only to be taken to 049 south then one
day
something changed zero four nine told dr
morstead that its work was done
that it accomplished what it had wanted
to do and could someone remove the cured
animal from itself
i think you'd find that it's quite the
work of art a triumph
049 said through the intercom when the
removal team entered the cell they found
the orangutan
or what was left of it it was lying in
the corner of the cell
the top of its skull had been removed
leaving its brain exposed
on its face was the expression of
relaxation and from its mouth it issued
very soft squeaks
like that of an infant 049 said
tell dr morrister that its rage
mechanism no longer exists
i've removed the amygdala and made some
changes to the hypothalamus and limbic
system
it is cured and quite harmless
the next day dr morstead announced that
he wanted to visit 049
cell himself after which he heard a
course of disapproval from his
colleagues
all telling him that 049 was now too
dangerous
dr ham was sick replied morested and 049
has assured us that he would never take
another human life
he's never lied to us i'm going to take
him at his word
it appeared that 049 had created the
perfect specimen
so what was next dr morstead had to know
everyone is sick 049 told dr morristed
after the two had talked for a couple of
minutes
the great pandemic has started fear not
doctor
i have a cure no longer will you humans
spread your disease
i'm afraid you are wrong replied the
doctor this pandemic you speak of does
not exist
we can happily live with our pathogens
we have done so for millennia
dr morstead became angry that he
couldn't get through to zero four nine
i'm afraid you are suffering from
paranoia it is you who need to be cured
you have no idea said 049 standing up
what are you doing shouted morristead
you promised you wouldn't hurt a human
again
i'm not hurting you i'm healing you
049 said and leapt across the room in a
flash
placing a hand on the doctor's head more
stead slumped to the ground
they were being watched in the
observation room and this had gone too
far
he had to be moved to the containment
cells permanently
mobile task force epsilon 11 was right
on the scene and burst through the door
now imagination 049 said to himself
those humans have no imagination at all
he began walking towards the task force
who opened fire on the anomaly
but the bullets bounced off its black
code and mask
scp-049 calmly touched each of the
members of the task force
one by one draining the life from them
the last one standing
stopped firing and attempted to run but
again 049 leapt across the room
black cape billowing out behind him and
gently touched the man causing him to
drop to the floor
zero four nine stepped over the bodies
of the fallen team and walked out of the
containment cell
the full details of what happened next
are available only to the o5 council
what are sometimes called the overseers
the redacted report that is available
reads
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 02 site 19
subject scp-049 date of breach
redacted euclid class scp-049 breach
cell and subsequently gained access to
adjoining rooms and nearby buildings
breach lasted approximately three days
and five hours
total casualties redacted with redacted
number of survivors requiring
incineration therapy
course of action department of science
alchemy division suggested injecting
anti-transmogrify
disinfected into class-d former
prisoners who were transported to sight
and allowed them to come into contact
with scp-049
scp failed to reanimate injected
prisoners and cure them
scp-049 acknowledged this failure and
surrendered to mobile task force alpha 1
scp-049 then requested to be contained
present containment under responsibility
of redacted rejected
present location of scp-049 redacted
end of report
you